and some more developments in the last
few minutes uh in the cabinet reshuffle
more people apparently on the way up uh
first of all we saw uh steve barkley
who you may remember
as a brexit cabinet minister
arriving in downing street
and then shortly after him uh
anne-marie trevelyan
uh arrived now she you may remember
lost her job when the merger took place
between the foreign office
and the international development agency
she was promised a return
and is now tipped to come back into the
government well let's go to our chief
political correspondent john craig who's
in down street and i should say john one
other piece of information we've had in
the last few minutes oliver dowden uh
going to be the new uh co-chair of the
conservative party along with the
controversial ben elliott uh
so tell us what's going on
well i can tell you that mr dowden
looked pretty pleased to be party
chairman as we was discussing a few uh
moments ago he's a former tory hq
staffer he was deputy chief of staff
when david cameron was party leader um
and he nobody knows the party machine
better
he's very much a party organization
person and uh he will obviously want to
shake up the party's election fighting
ahead of uh elections uh next spring of
course
i said to him party chairman he said
that's correct and he smiled he looks
really pleased to have got that job he's
been culture secretary
so
no more dealing with the media and all
their reforms channel 4 privatization
all that sort of stuff party chairman
now he will become i would imagine a
leading spokesman for the government in
broadcast interviews firefighting if you
like when there are controversies
because he's seen as a pretty assured
media performer so that is mr dowden mp
for heart smear remember a former party
chairman cecil parkinson was mp for that
seat a few years back um also
confirmation that uh mark spencer the
big burly ruddy-faced farmer who is is
the conservatives chief whip he is
staying in that job now there had been
speculation that he might replace um
george eustis as defra secretary but uh
for now uh mr eustace survives we
haven't seen or heard from him today
mark spencer who's had some tough times
uh as chief whip especially when uh
there was no uh a majority for the
tories uh he uh well that was before his
time but actually also
since uh the prime minister boris
johnson became prime minister there have
been some pretty tough battles even with
the 80-seat majority uh because of
course on covid legislation so on big
rebellions by the tory old guard mark
spencer stays as chief whip as you've
said
um anne marie trevelyan is in there
genuinely didn't seem to know what she
was going to be offered
steve barclay who has his current job as
treasury chief secretary
well the trade portfolio is vacant now
that liz trust has moved up to foreign
secretary so perhaps one of them will
get that job
you